what are what are the vital things you
have to to know to be a professional
director won't you know I often I speak
at film schools I'm inviting sometimes
to speak at film schools I don't
searched a lot that but I feel that too
many films would I see by young
directors are kind of totally derivative
from films they know nothing about life
it's all what they know about life is
derived from watching films and so you
getting back earlier you sink into
cliches and you don't make it new ya
mekia I I people to ask me did you go to
film school I said no but almost as it
was almost well I worked in a stress
packing house how much far I worked a
goodyear tire and rubber i worked in
restaurants that was my film school what
do you mean i said well i watch or white
people work and they live and
interconnect and and I think that I said
when I were to goodyear tire and rubber
i said that stood me for a whole
lifetime of directing all those people
that I work with and so I think you
should go out and get jobs but this is
not necessary this is not trying to
suggest this to everybody some people
are capable have the insights already
there's some great elma did Laura I'm
some was great Spanish director others
and I think like Amberson adjusted
master I don't think he knows his
knowledge of life is so deep yes sir he
didn't work in an abattoir but for
whatever the books but you're not you've
got to have some knowledge about life
you know that's the most important thing
you've got to make a statement about
about the eye it's funny when I went to
Australia to make this film waked right
which is going to open on october the
19th at the new art cinema and i'm going
to introduce it in CUNY a man came up to
me and he said you're here to rubbish us
aren't you this is an Australian Open
yell back you're here to rubbish us
no Joe all yeah you're going to hear the
rubbish us I said listen here I don't
know you well enough to rubbish you and
anyway i'm a director I don't criticize
I observe and I empathize and to quote
my culture here are Anton Chekhov he
said I I'm not the judge of my
characters and their best witness that
said that set is shivered my backbone
when i read that i am not the judge of
my gorgeous I'm there Beth madness
wouldn't if I'm their best witness so
when I made we can fight deadly kravis
City curves does horrible things but
some i want to get inside what making
him behave like that's what interests me
is not judging people and you that's not
art that's not directing it's not
writing is this nothing I don't know
what that is as for the courtrooms so I
think the knowledge of the human heart
in human soul however you arrive at it I
had to go and experience it some people
have instinctive knowledge of the
mechanisms of the human heart but yeah I
think that so much to me is the most
valuable thing in being a film director
you